sono simona panseri direttrice della
comunicazione di google per il sud
europa e mi è stato chiesto di parlarvi
della correlazione tra connessione ad
internet e felicità col titolo un po
provocatorie di dis connessi e felici
nel momento in cui vi parlo forse mai
come oggi così tante persone hanno
potuto misurare l'utilità dei servizi di
internet nella loro vita quotidiana
anzi a volte direi anche l'essenzialità
grazie ad internet
chi di noi è potuto restare al sicuro
nelle proprie case ha continuato a
lavorare studiare a fare ginnastica
musica fare esperimenti in cucina a
parlare con i nonni con gli amici farsi
consegnare il cibo e beni di prima
necessità
e poi ci sono tutti quelli che hanno
potuto grazie ad internet trovare i
clienti continuare la propria attività
consegnare la frutta la verdura vendere
il formaggio la lista è assolutamente
lunghissima
quello che conta è che ciascuno di noi
in qualche modo ha potuto sfruttare
l'utilità dei servizi di internet a
proprio vantaggio
forse io non direi per la propria
felicità ma senz'altro per il proprio
benessere
e allora vi chiederete perché parlare di
correlazione tra disconnessione e
benessere
facciamo un esempio vi è mai successo di
andare a letto dopo una giornata
infinita e quando state per
addormentarmi finalmente proprio sul più
bello quel pin
[Musica]
lo smartphone è in carica in un'altra
stanza perché ovviamente non volete che
sia l'ultima cosa da vedere prima di
addormentarsi e la prima da vedere al
risveglio e quindi per vedere di che
cosa si tratta
bisogna alzarsi se vi alzate ci vorrà
del tempo per riaddormentarmi se non vi
alzate non andate a controllare che non
sia niente di urgente passerete la notte
a rigirarsi nel letto con l'agitazione
che ci fosse un problema
poi probabilmente dopo tutte queste
considerazioni sono se n'è andato lo
stesso quindi vi alzate era vostra madre
con un problema importante il capo che
mai vi avrebbe disturbato a quest'ora se
non si fosse trattato di qualcosa di
critico oppure cosa è successo a me una
volta il vicino di casa che mentre
mi ha cercato alle 5 del mattino per
avvisarmi che purtroppo casa mia si era
allagata dal balcone scendevano delle
cascate del niagara e proprio in quel
momento i pompieri stavano rompendo il
vetro per entrare dalla finestra
mi auguro per voi che mediamente non si
tratta di niente di tutto ciò
probabilmente è solo che non avete
controllato non avete eliminato le
notifiche di qualche applicazione e
adesso c'è qualcuno che vuole suggerire
qualcosa da vedere un amico che ha
commentato qualcosa qualcosa da comprare
a me queste situazioni scatenano delle
montagne russe di emozioni che vanno
dall'ansia e la preoccupazione al
sollievo quando non è niente di grave
alla rabbia tour feroce perché sono
stata svegliata per nulla e a questo
punto prima di addormentarmi debole già
almeno 350 pagine del libro quando penso
questo susseguirsi di emozioni mi
vengono in mente due acronimi che sono
diventati abbastanza famosi nel mondo
anglosassone che sono fumo e gioco sono
sta per fear of missing out ed è la
paura di non sapere che cosa sta
succedendo di perdersi qualcosa
il bisogno di sapere sempre chi fa cosa
quando che cosa ha postato chi è stato
insomma vivere dipendendo dalle
notifiche
all'opposto gioco sta per joy of missing
out e cioè il piacere di concedersi del
tempo nel quale di queste cose non ci si
preoccupa
e questo vale per la vita personale e
per la vita professionale
se voi in questo momento fosse davanti a
me poter stanziare la mano vi chiederei
quanti di voi tengono attive le
notifiche sul telefono
quanti l'hanno fatto in modo consapevole
e lo fanno per una scelta
quando ho cominciato a lavorare in
google mi ricordo che si è scatenata
l'ansia da notifica delle mail le e mail
arrivano letteralmente in continuazione
quindi è materialmente impossibile
eliminare quei simboli
email dal telefono
il problema è che questo generava una
pressione fortissima che peraltro
nessuno mi aveva imposto e che generava
ansia ma non mi rendeva certo più
produttiva del tutto inutile aver tolto
le notifiche non significa che non
reggono il mail certo che le leggo non
significa che mi perdo delle cose
importanti però sono io a scegliere
quando lecco posso decidere di non farlo
in continuazione perché ho bisogno di
concentrarmi su un lavoro o perché sono
fuori dall'orario di lavoro e non
significa che lo faccia di rado la
differenza tra spesso e in continuazione
e fondamentale ed è la mia scelta
eliminata la notifica eliminata la
pressione vino meglio lavoro meglio
allora questa è una battaglia contro le
notifiche perché notifica è uguale ansia
no non è così anzi vi faccio un altro
esempio di una notifica esattamente
opposta la sveglia
io sono tra quelli che si svegliano
pochi minuti prima del suono della
sveglia quindi tecnicamente la sveglia
una notifica della quale non avrei
bisogno però l'appunto sempre perché mi
consente di dormire tranquillamente
senza svegliarmi con la preoccupazione
di non riuscire a svegliarmi nel momento
giusto
la notifica delle mail per me crea
pressione ed è un generatore di ansia e
la sveglia invece è una notifica che
toglie anzi è migliore a mio benessere e
mi rendo conto che non siamo tutti
uguali e che normalmente la sveglia
viene vissuta più come un fattore di
disturbo non un evento di tortura
piuttosto che di benessere però non vuol
dire non è sempre così e infatti anche
in vacanza o in durante i fine settimana
la sveglia non appunto perché perché non
mi serve
e allora questo è il punto chiave nella
rapporto tra connessione e benessere
non esiste una regola diversa da quello
che ci serve è proprio in questo
rapporto fondato sull'utilità che si
trova quell'equilibrio che genera il
benessere e l'equilibrio è evidente
l'abbiamo già detto prima è
assolutamente personale e quello che per
me funziona adesso non funziona per voi
non funzionava magari due anni fa
potrebbe non funzionare più domani ma il
punto fondamentale è che ciascuno di noi
abbia il controllo abbia il controllo
psicologico e abbia anche una serie di
strumenti che gli consentono di
esercitare questo controllo e per questo
per esempio che in google
abbiamo sviluppato tutti questi
strumenti che consentono alle persone di
gestire il controllo delle impostazioni
in modo estremamente articolato in gmail
youtube in android è possibile
personalizzare tutte le impostazioni di
notifica in modo estremamente
dettagliato upper up e non solo dicendo
ricevono ricevo le notifiche ma anche
decidendo se le si vuole ricevere in
modalità silenziosa oppure no o ancora
abbiamo sviluppato la funzione non
disturbare che elimina tutte le
notifiche ma mi permette naturalmente di
impostare delle eccezioni per ricevere
per esempio le telefonate importanti e
in questo modo estremamente utile sia
che abbiate bisogno di concentrarmi su
un progetto sia che vogliate dedicare il
tempo alle persone con le quali state
sta passando questo tempo sia che
vogliate magari evitare di essere
svegliati di notte dal fatidico ping di
cui sopra o poi per esempio in google
wifi c'è possibilità di scegliere un
orario nel quale disconnettere i
dispositivi e non tutti si può decidere
anche di disconnettere solo alcuni
dispositivi dal wifi e chi di voi ha dei
figli adolescenti può capire l'utilità
degli accordi
quindi la conclusione è disconnessi e
felici no connessi e felici
no il rapporto tra la connessione
benessere passa attraverso la
consapevolezza e il controllo per avere
sempre a disposizione tutto quello che
ci serve è solo quello grazie